hi Stacy how are you I'm good day how
are you better than I deserve what's up
okay well I have a couple questions for
you first one is my husband does
traveling construction so we move all
over the world more in Crystal River now
and this job they last about another
year and I just got on board with sure
program probably two months ago and I
was probably the worst in a family with
the money
um but I'm struggling with being able to
figure out if I want to do the thousand
dollar emergency fund first or if we
need to save up traveling money first
and then I've looked into your financial
piece University and actually went got a
job I'm like a good job and I'll they'll
pay for it in this very day that I went
we got a letter from the IRS mmm now
they're actually you know long but
you're still on track you at least got
something on hey Matt yeah so and I'm
nowhere in town so if you saved your
thousand dollar emergency fund and you
had to move and you were broke that
would be an emergency maybe a super big
emergency so it's the same thing okay no
different is it that saved a thousand
thousand at save your thousand dollars
and then start getting out of that when
will you when will you be moving well
you saw traveling money
you mean you mean to move after this
job's over right right well because we
were going to actually use his VA loan
and buy house but then after hearing you
I'm like oh we don't want to do that now
they may have to travel another couple
years with him until we get all our debt
paid off and we'll be able to purchase a
home until you lay in a place you need
to be staying in the same place cuz you
know yeah um someone else every two
years is a good way to go broke right
well for the kids we do that three to
the school and we were thinking well
well boss think really located home that
he can leave for the week and come home
on the weekend and instead of us having
a following around but we were going to
do that with the VA loan and we're like
yeah in a way to be out of debt first so
so traveling money means when this job
is up moving right right okay and when
will the job be on we got another year
here okay and your house
income as what about 90,000 okay I think
you can save up the move towards closer
to the move and in the meantime must
work the baby steps okay I mean what's
it take to move um around 5,000 okay how
quick can you say 5,000 bucks I know
I've been really struggling with this I
try I can get $1,000 as much for some
reason hopefully but in August we will
have $1,000 I was going to see if it
would be right to not pay something in
order to take the financial you make
$90,000 a year I know where is it going
well our household bills once we pay
just our bills house we rent and which
we got stupid loans everywhere now cars
and you know how much you owe on your
cars uh we know 22,000 and like 25 or
something but they're not worth that
much we're upside down 4000 in the tar
in the suburban but your car poor bad
these cars oh yeah they're killing you I
didn't want you need to work your way
out of those cars and you need to um you
know and but here's the thing you need
to figure out how long it's going to
take you to save $5,000 you're
disorganized you don't have a plan you
need to get on every dollar calm it's
free get your budget built you and your
husband go over the budget start working
it together with the goal of a thousand
dollars and then let's get some cars
sold and let's list some debts smallest
to largest and work our way right down
from that right down that list and as
you do that you're going to free up more
and more money and then you can look up
and go hey we got to move in three
months so we got to stop our debt
snowball right now because we gotta save
up five thousand bucks right quick for
the move because we can't go in debt
anymore and you know if save up our
money for that but you should be able to
do that in a couple of months making 90
thousand bucks but you're just
disorganized right now and as you said
you got bills coming out your ears but
you know you got thousand dollars a
month in car payments and wonder you're
broke you guys thinking rolling-stock
sit in the driveway just eating your
lunch so these things got to go it's you
a couple beater cars and get really
dadgum car payments
and that's a big part of your situation
me send you copy the book the Total
Money Makeover it'll help you through
the whole process and show you exactly
what to do
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
than the Dave Ramsey channel don't tell
them I said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you